[Musik]
[Applaus]
von den fünf größten Volkswirtschaften
dieser Welt ist eine gerade zu verdammt
eine Seemacht zu sein wir reden nicht
von den USA die auch eine Seemacht sind
wir reden von Japan denn Japan ist ein
Archipel aus tausenden Inseln und die
müssen geschützt werden seine Hoheit und
Binnengewässer haben eine größere Fläche
als die Landmasse aller japanischen
Inseln zusammengenommen wir reden hier
von 430.000 Quadratkilometer Wasser
gegenüber knapp 380.000 Quadratkilometer
festen Boden und darüber hinaus müssen
wir noch die maritimen Wirtschaftszonen
hinzuzählen in denen Japan über
besondere Rechte verfügt z.B in Sachen
Fischerei und dem Abbau von Rohstoffen
[Musik]
nachdem sie rechtsabkommen der Vereinten
Nationen erstreckt sich diese Zone in
der Regel 200 seemeil von einer Küste
entfernt aufs Meer hinaus kurz gesagt
Japan hat viel mehr Seegebiete als
Landmasse zu verteidigen und das ist
noch nicht alles die Hälfte der und 126
Millionen Einwohner Japans lebt in der
Nähe der knapp 30.000 km langen
Küstenlinie all das macht Japan zu einem
Land das sich im Wesentlichen dem mehr
zuwendet und zwar in allen Belangen im
Alltag in der Wirtschaft und in der
Verteidigung spielt diese immer die
Hauptrolle
so werden zum Beispiel rund 99% von
Japans Außenhandel per Schiff
abgewickelt der Schiff kommen rund 80%
aller Energierohstoffe
erdölkompaktischen nur über das Meer mit
anderen Worten ohne sichere Meere wäre
die gesamte japanische Wirtschaft enorm
verwundbar daher muss jegliche
Sicherheitsplanung für das Land die Lage
auf dem Meer mit einkalkulieren der
Ozean zählt also doppelt und dreifach im
Lande auf jeden Fall Sonne
[Musik]
und wie ihr sicher alle wisst in der
maritimen Nachbarschaft aus Asiens braut
sich was zusammen da ist China gerade
dabei die größte Flotte der Welt zu
bauen gemessen an der Zahl der Schiffe
china will die Meere in dieser Welt
gegen beherrschen und das hat natürlich
Folgen für die Nachbarländer
einschließlich Japan seht euch mal diese
Schlagzeile an Dritte November 2022
Chinas Marine stellt Rekord bei
Eingriffen in Japans Hoheit Gewässer auf
Schiffe der volksbefreiungsmarine sind
seit 2004/8 mal in japanische
Hoheitsgewässer eingedrungen fünfmal
seit Oktober 2021 es ist nicht
verwunderlich dass die Japaner zunehmend
beunruhigt sind und es ist der Grund
warum sich militärisch der seit einiges
gut in Japan vor allem bei der
japanischen Marine in diesem Video
erzählen wir euch wie Japan seine
Verteidigung und Kampfkraft auf sie
ausbaut um seine Küsten
zu schützen man kann mittlerweile mit
Flug und Recht behaupten das mit Japan
eine neue militärische Großmacht
heranwächst eine Großmacht die schon
ganz allein das Zeug dazu hätte dass von
manchen als mächtiger eingeschätzte
China in die Knie zu zwingen ihr glaubt
mir nicht dann bleibt dran und erfahrt
was genau ist damit auf sich hat am Ende
dieses Videos werdet ihr genau verstehen
warum es er China ist dass sich vor dem
neuen Japan fürchten muss als umgekehrt
[Musik]
die Seewege müssen frei sein
was ihr hier seht sind die wichtigsten
Schifffahrtsrouten die sogenannten
sealiens of communication es sind Wege
über tausende Seemeilen über diese läuft
aber nicht nur ein Großteil des
japanischen Handels sondern auch der
Handel anderer Volkswirtschaften die
China oder Südkorea dabei geht es nicht
nur um Konsumgüter sondern auch um
Maschinen für die Industrie und Importe
wichtiger Rohstoffe und Energie also
alles was Volkswirtschaften so brauchen
um zu funktionieren
[Musik]
ein Beispiel etwa die Hälfte des von
Japan importierten flüssig Erdgases
passiert einem der Hotspots auf den auf
der Karte dargestellten Seewen besonders
wichtig sind hier die Straße von Hormus
die Straße von Malaka und die
Taiwanstraße wir reden hier über die
gigantische Mengen die japans Wirtschaft
braucht mit etwas mehr als 74 Millionen
Tonnen pro Jahr ist Japan der 2 größte
LG importler der Welt gleich in China
2021 den Spitzen das eine
[Musik]
aber Japan braucht auch Erdöl und beim
schwarzen Gold ist die Bedeutung der
genannten offshore Hotspots noch viel
größer 90% des Erdöl ist das Japan
importiert kommt nämlich aus dem Nahen
Osten der Rohstoff muss also an Stellen
vorbei die berühmt berüchtigt sind für
alle möglichen unschönen Dinge die auf
sie passieren können
die Straße von hormos zum Beispiel Trend
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate und
den Oman vom Iran sie ist weniger als 40
km breit und alle Schiffe bewegen sich
durch festgelegte ein- und
ausfahrtsrouten die was bloß zwei Meilen
breit sind allein das also ist für jeden
der ein Containerschiff oder ein Tanker
steuert eine große Herausforderung hinzu
kommt dass die Straße von muss eine Art
maritimes brennpunktviertel darstellt wo
auch gerne mal gehört wird hier sind ist
die iranischen Paschas die immer wieder
Handelsschiffe bedrohen oder sogar
angreifen 13 juni 2019 japanisches
Schiff in der Straße von Homos
angegriffen USA beschuldigen Iran
4 Januar 2021 südkoreanischer Tanker in
der Straße von Hormus durch Iran
beschlagnahmt diese Schlagzeilen sind
nur zwei Beispiele aber die Liste ist
lang sehr lang und die Spannungen neben
der Zeit eher noch zu als ab
deshalb ist es kein Wunder dass auch
japanische Kriegsschiffe in dieser
Wasserstraße kreuzen es geht hier
schließlich darum die Lebensadern dieses
Landes zu sichern der Handelsschiffe
sieht das an
japanisches Kriegsschiff bricht in den
Golf auf um die Ölversorgung zu
überwachen tausende japanische Schiffe
durchqueren jedes Jahr den Golf darunter
Schiffe den 19 unseres Öl transportieren
es ist die Lebensader Japans ist die
Straße von muss erst mal passiert wird
es aber auch nicht viel einfacher die
Handelsschiff von ultrank damit sie
Südkorea oder Japan müssen durch die
sicherheitspolitisch heißen Gewässer
Südostasien es handelt sich um mehrere
auf den ein doppeltes Risiko besteht
besprechen über China und über Piraten
wenn ich euch fragen würde welches
Seegebiet dieser Welt am meisten unter
charakterie und schiffseinführungen
leidet denken viele vielleicht an das
Horn von Afrika rund um Somalia nicht
wahr und das ist falsch das Horn von
Afrika war früher einmal die Wiege der
modernen Piraterie doch die Region mit
den meisten Piraten befindet sich heute
in Südostasien 60% aller Fälle von
pereteriegeschehen dort der Piraten
Hotspot hat sich nach Osten verschoben
wir sprechen vor allem über die Gebiete
der Straße von Malaka und über die
sonderstraße sowie über die Küstenland
Gebiete von Vietnam Kambodscha
Indonesien und Malaysia aber selbst
nördlich von Taiwan gab es bereits
Angriff auf Schiffe wenn wir noch einmal
einen Blick auf die Karte werfen könnte
erkennen dass die wichtigsten Import und
Export Routen Japans und Südkoreas
ebenfalls dort vorbei führen
natürlich müssten die betroffenen Länder
und die Anrainerstaaten hier für
Sicherheit sorgen doch es gibt ein
großes Problem dabei viele dieser
südostasiatischen Länder besitzen keine
starken Seestreitkräfte oder sonstige
Ressourcen um ihre Meere zu sichern
deswegen müssen Japan und Südkorea dies
selbst übernehmen oder sind auf die USA
angewiesen oder eben auf China dass er
eigentlich auch selbst ein Interesse an
der Sicherheit der Seewege hat
allerdings ist meine Tokio natürlich
alles andere als begeistert darüber dass
die Sicherheit des eigenen Handels vom
Wohlwollen der Chinesen abhängt aus
diesem Grund fährt Japan schon seit
Jahrzehnten eine ehrgeizige maritime
Sicherheitspolitik
bereits
1981 legte Premierminister Senko Suzuki
den Grundstein für die
Verteidigungspolitik der 1000 Meilen
Seewege mit ihrer Hilfe halten sich
japanische militärische für das Recht
vor bis zu 1000 Seemeilen von der
eigene anzugreifen natürlich nur
Zuschuss des eigenen Handels und das
erklärt zum Teil warum Japan so viele
Gebietsansprüche auch weit entfernte
Inseln erhebt in vielen Fällen handelt
es sich ja eher um vom Ozean umgebene
Felsen als Insel wo die Ansprüche
erscheint fast schon absorgt aber Japan
schaut hier keine Kosten und Mühen und
es sich dafür sogar auf so manche
diplomatischen Reibereien mit Russland
oder China eineinhalb
wie gesagt wir haben darüber schon mal
in einem Video gesprochen aber der Sinn
dahinter ist die Verteidigungslinie auf
sie so weit wie möglich von den
japanischen Hauptinseln wegzuverschieben
und das erklärt dann auch Nachrichten
die folgende Dritter Februar 2016 japan
will Millionen für winzige Inseln 1000
Meilen südlich von Tokio ausgeben doch
so ambitioniert japansverteidigung auf
sie auch erscheint es mangelte bisher an
den militärischen Ressourcen eine seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gegenläufige
Entwicklung ist nämlich die
traditionelle Zurückhaltung der Japaner
bei Rüstung und militärischen Engagement
die Folge dieser Zurückhaltung ist das
Chinas militärische Einfluss in
Südostasien auf weniger Widerstände
stieß und sich stärker ausbreiten konnte
[Musik]
die Lage ist teilweise recht kompliziert
denn China benutzt den vorhin erwähnten
maritimen verteidigungsansatz der
Japaner als Vorwand um sich militärisch
im und Unterschied chinesischen Meer
bereit zu machen angeblich um sich vor
Japan zu schützen und das für dazu dass
sich im Meer zwischen den beiden Ländern
jeweiligen Interessengebiete
überschneiden außerdem ließen die
Modernisierung der chinesischen
Streitkräfte und der Ausbau der
chinesischen Marine Tokio bisher mit
großen Unbehagen zurück dieses Unbehagen
Wuchs zu Shira Angst an als PS
Ambitionen immer größer wollen die Rede
ist natürlich von der Übernahme Hongs
und den ständigen Feindseligkeiten
gegenüber Taiwan es ist Tokios Furcht zu
einer Art Satellitenstadt Chinesen zu
werden oder zumindest als ein Land zu
enden das von Peking sowohl wollen
abhängig ist denn der dritte gefährliche
Hotspot liegt in Form der Taiwanstraße
direkt vor Japans Haustür oder erklärt
vielleicht am eindrücklichsten warum
Japan seine Seemacht ausbauen will
[Musik]
die Straße von Taiwan ist das
militärisch am stärksten angespannte
Gebiet in den ostasiatischen Meeren wir
sprechen über einen mehrenge die für
Japan besonders wichtig ist denn Japan
hat enorme wirtschaftliche und
strategische Interessen in Taiwan wir
haben darüber sogar ein eigenes Video
gedreht taiwan ist ein wichtiger
Handelspartner aber nicht nur der
Japaner und so hängt die gesamte
japanische Wirtschaft von der Stabilität
dieser pulverfassregion ab in der China
ständig zündet und die größte Bedrohung
für Japan liegt darin dass Peking immer
mehr in der Lage ist Japan unter Druck
zu setzen ja fast schon zu strangulieren
doch welche Möglichkeiten haben die
Japaner und ihre Wirtschaft ihre
Versorgungswege und die nationale
Integrität des Landes zu schützen
[Musik]
nun zum einen können Sie internationale
Allianzen schmieden oder vertiefen genau
das passiert gerade mit den Vereinigten
Staaten mit Großbritannien mit Indien
mit Australien und sogar mit Südkorea
schaut euch mal die folgenden
Schlagzeilen an 6 September 2022
Südkorea und Japan führen erstmal seit
sechs Jahren verteidigungsgespräche auf
höchster Ebene Achter September 2022
Indien und Japan halten weitere
Militärübungen ab um die Beziehungen zu
stärken Japan und Australien verbessern
sicherheitspakt gegen Bedrohung durch
China 5 November 2022 japan will
militärpakt mit Großbritannien
unterzeichnen da Verbündete die
Bedrohung durch China sehen und im
Gegensatz zu Deutschland vollzieht sich
in Japan in Sachen Militär wirklich eine
wahre Zeiten wende man setzt in erster
Linie auf die Marine und Abwehrsysteme
gegen ballistische Raketen aber um was
genau geht es dabei wie sieht die
japanische Strategie aus genau das sehen
wir uns jetzt genauer
Japans neues 2022 Papier zur
Verteidigung des Landes fordert eine
massive Aufrüstung des Militärs um China
zu begegnen
zeitenwände die Japaner machens vor
eines kann man mit Fug Unrecht behaupten
Japan ist militärisch auf die Weltbühne
zurückgekehrt und am meisten profitieren
die Marine und die Luftwaffe vom neuen
Geldregen die die japanische Regierung
über ihr Militär ausschüttet das Ziel
ist es eine Art Marine Luftwaffe zu
schaffen die große Seegebiete
verteidigen kann
man will hier von US-Truppen unabhängig
agieren können und auch den Chinesen
Konkurrenz machen dafür will Japan in
den nächsten fünf Jahren etwas mehr als
300 Milliarden Dollar für seine
Streitkräfte ausgeben so werden sie
künftig mindestens zwei Prozent ihres
BIP in die Verteidigung stecken während
es bisher kaum ein Prozent war und mit
diesem Plan werden die Japaner den
drittgrößten Militärhaushalt der Welt
haben hinter der Vereinigten Staaten und
China
salopp gesagt Japan wächst wieder zu
einem militärischen Riesen heran und
über was für Projekte reden wir genau
ein Beispiel sind zwei neue Zerstörer
die ballistische raketenabwehren sollen
in diese investiert Japan derzeit rund
7,1 Milliarden Dollar nur zwei weitere
Schiffe das klingt nach nicht besonders
viel aber die Realität sieht ganz anders
aus
[Musik]
nach ihrer Auslieferung im Jahr 2027
werden sie die größten Zerstörer Japans
sein unter den größten militärschiffen
in asiatischen Gewässern gehören die
neuen Zerstörer sind jeweils 210 Meter
lang und 40 Meter breit und haben eine
Verdrängung von schätzungsweise 20.000
Tonnen beide Schiffe werden mit dem
modernsten Eagles aufwärtssystem der
Amerikaner ausgestattet was derzeit die
Creme de la Creme ihre Klasse ist
[Musik]
und es gibt noch mehr spektakuläres
Kriegsgerät her Japan nimmt die erste
neue Mehrzweck Fregatte der Mogami
Klasse in Betrieb die Commando ist das
erste von 22 geplanten Schiffen der
Klasse die über Fähigkeiten verfügen
wird die noch nie zuvor auf einer
japanischen Fregatte zu sehen waren
diese neue Gruppe von Fregatten wird
Japan für sie überwachungsmission
einsetzen auch im Südchinesischen Meer
wo es viele Probleme gibt
[Musik]
außerdem begann Japan im März 2022 auch
den zweiten Hubschrauberträger der isumo
Klasse so um Touristen das F35 Kampfjets
drauf landen können man ist gerade dabei
42 f35b Senkrechtstarter aus den USA zu
beschaffen damit diese von den Schiffen
aus operieren können Staats- und
Landungen mit Maschinen des US-Militärs
sind schon Ende 2021 absolviert worden
die beiden Schiffe dieser Klasse werden
damit die ersten Flugzeugträger unter
japanischer Flagge Seite Kaiserzeit
sagen außerdem hat auch Japans Luftwaffe
bereits 1135a im Betrieb oder in
Bestellung zusammen mit dem Essen 35B
wird das Land in wenigen Jahren sagen
und schreibe 147 Flugzeuge dieses
Kampfjet Modells betreiben und das wäre
die zweitgrößte F35 Flotte nach den
Vereinigten Staaten
gemeinsam mit den amerikanischen Drohnen
und zwei neuen Boeing Casey forty-six
Flugzeugen werde dass die
luftverteidigungsfähigkeit der Japaner
auf See kräftig auch
[Musik]
und haltet euch fest denn vor kurzem ist
noch folgende Nachricht ans Licht
gekommen 9 dezember 2022 Japan
Großbritannien und Italien planen
Kampfjets der sechsten Generation die
mit den modernsten Kampfflugzeugen der
Welt konkurrieren sollen ganz genau
Japan Großbritannien und Italien werden
mit Unterstützung der USA gemeinsam eine
hochmode Kampfjet entwickelt der ihre
F35 flotten ergänzen und die
militärischen Fähigkeiten Chinas und
Russland weit übertreffen sollen die
Japaner denken sogar über die
Entwicklung eine Hyperschall Rakete die
bis 2030 in Betrieb gehen soll dritten
November 2022 Japan erwägt Einsatz von
Hyperschall Raketen bis 2030 zur
Stärkung der Abschreckung beeindruckend
nicht wahr noch mal wir sprechen über
Japan und ich denke dass ihr wisst das
Japan seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in
Sachen Militär immer extrem
zurückhaltend war und zwar nicht nur
wegen des friedlichen Geistes seiner
Verfassung sondern auch aus einer Art
gesellschaftlicher Überzeugung
[Musik]
aber all das ist jetzt passé die
Spielregeln haben sich für Japan
geändert und zwar mit dem militärischen
Aufstieg Chinas mit einem aggressiven
Nordkorea das immer wieder mit Raketen
provoziert und angesichts eines
Russlands dass sich wie ein Amokläufer
aufhört und bitte vergesst nicht bei dem
Nest genannten Schulten ein weiteres
Detail Japan und Russland Grenzen
praktisch aneinander und haben einen
offenen Territorialstreit um die
kurileninsel
[Musik]
wir haben darüber bereits in einem
früheren Video gesprochen und ich werde
es euch verlinken aber neben
militärische Ausrüstung gehört zum
Sicherheitsbedürfnis eines Staates auch
die passende Verteidigungsstrategie und
diese wurde gerade neu verabschiedet sie
erfordert nun zum Schutze Japans auch
die Fähigkeit gegen Angriffe auf
Militärbasen im Ausland durchzuführen
darüber hinaus schließt Japans premier
von Yorki China nicht aus bei
Bedrohungen auch präventiv Schläge
auszuführen
16 dezember 2022 Japan genehmigt das
Recht feindliche Stützpunkte anzugreifen
klar dafür bedarf ist der Reform der
japanischen Verfassung doch solch eine
Reform findet in der japanischen Politik
immer mehr Befürworter und sollte es
wirklich so weit kommen dann wird sich
das Blatt in der Region schnell wenden
es wird das total restourcen hungrige
China sein das vom Wohlwollen der
Japaner abhängig ist wenn Tokio es
wollte könnte es mit seiner
militärischen Sinn macht die Wirtschaft
des Roten Riesen völlig zusammenbrechen
lassen
das vielleicht größte Problem für die
Chinesen werden die Japaner sein Chinas
Marine ist für den Küstenschutz und
küstennahe Einsätze ausgelegt und nur
etwa 10% ihrer Schiffe sind in der Lage
sich mehr als 1000 Meilen von der Küste
zu entfernen nur sehr wenige können
weiter als 2000 Meilen fahren china hat
keine wirklichen Verbündeten außer
vielleicht Nordkorea also es ist ein
Linker Unmöglichkeit seine Macht überall
hinzu projizieren Japan entgegen hat
eine Marine die in der Lage ist einen
oder gar zwei Kontinente weit zu fahren
zu kämpfen wenn es hart auf hart kommt
können die Japaner einfach einen kleinen
Einsatztrupp an Singapur vorbei in den
Indischen Ozean schicken und die
chinesischen Ressourcen Flüsse und damit
auch China aus der Ferne zum Stillstand
bringen also das ist der Stand der Dinge
bei Japans Militärpolitik wenn der
Begriff zeitenwände derzeit für
Wiederaufrüstung steht so ist wohl Japan
das Land das klotzt dazu kleckern
vielleicht ist das ein Beispiel dass ich
jedes Land in welchem der Begriff
zeitenwände erfunden wurde mal abschauen
sollte aber diese Frage leitende erstmal
an euch weiter sollte Deutschland
ebenfalls so stark aufrüsten die Japan
schließlich trug der schon einen Krieg
in Europa direkt vor der Haustür und
falls Ihr uns aus der Schweiz oder
Österreich anschaut was haltet ihr davon
außerdem glaubt ihr Japan wird in der
Region China militärisch in Schach
halten können vielleicht sogar alleine
oder mit Hilfe der Amerikaner also haut
in die Tasten und schreibt uns was ihr
dazu meint ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch das dabei gelernt haben was ja gibt
uns bitte Leiter sind
unsere Videos mehr zu ver natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit uns halt dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]